today is Monday the very first day of
June and this is gamespot news I'm Chris
waters here to power us through another
week of just less hosting on the show
fortunately Mary Kish did such a great
job last week that I basically just have
to ride her coattails until just comes
back next week everything will be gravy
plus there's like actual news today
don't want to hear it XCOM 2 boom
announced totally happening and I'm
totally excited and totally anxious
already the sequel to 4 axis games
turn-based tactical action hit is set 20
years after the events of xcom enemy
Unknown humanity has lost the war
totally your fault and aliens are now
building shiny happy cities which can
you believe it are concealing something
sinister you and your team of elite
soldiers that you named after my little
pony characters will jet around the
planet in your upgradeable mobile
headquarters and if Twilight Sparkle or
Pinkie Pie happens to get mauled by
super meat man or a snake with boobs
you'll be able to save them this time by
carrying their bodies to the extraction
point this ability along with new
soldier classes new enemies and mod
support round out some of the features
announced for XCOM 2 which is set to
arrive on PC this November no word yet
on a console release but it's got to
happen maybe they'll reveal some kind of
x console exclusivity deal at e3 during
the Microsoft or Sony press conferences
maybe tune in in two weeks to find out
after years of making delightful games
based on beloved characters and
universes Lego is taking a shot at the
King it's not Lego Jailhouse Rock it's
lego minecraft i mean lego worlds in a
trailer released today on minecraft
creator notches birthday no less WB
games announced that Lego world's is now
available on Steam early access
exploration and
EA shin and verbs written on the ground
were the main themes of the trailer
which featured a variety of mount and a
sick drill vehicle that looks a lot like
the TMNT mutant module Toya had when I
was a kid which was awesome lego worlds
is planned to be in early access
throughout 2015 while the team flushes
out the full feature list and they plan
to quote evaluate a release candidate in
early 2016 so what do you think
minecraft Ian's tempted to trade in your
voxels for bricks tell me in the
comments below a recent developer video
for Batman Arkham Knight has revealed
new details about the cape and Crusaders
new adventure according to director
Sefton Hill you can play from the start
of the game to the end of the game and
you won't see any loading screens the
video also said that the new game plus
mode will let you start with all of your
gadgets and XP from your previous play
through there are some details about
Batmobile weaponry and footage of the
Batmobile navigating a big sewer maze
created by the Riddler who knew Edward
nygma was such an ambitious engineer
alright two more quick ones and then
we're done for the day I promise first
up there's a patch coming for the
witcher 3 that will among other fixes
and optimizations make you unable to
light candles near chests and other
interactive objects in an effort to
reduce confusion and will boost the font
size for increased readability a list of
the most requested updates can be found
in our article at gamespot.com / news
and secondly Bungie has filed trademarks
for the terms ever verse and ever verse
trading company could this be connected
to bungees comment that they might
introduce a player trading system in
destiny is there a new mercantile
faction on its way to the reef perhaps
it's the reveal of the destiny
collectible card battle game I'll leave
you to speculate in the comments below
and discuss the news of the day with
your fellow news enthusiasts news Suzy
asst that's what you guys are just a
bunch of new Suzie estoy love news Suzy
azum for the news this wonderful
portmanteau and others coming your way
all week right here on gamespot news